we have case we have a case with the
indictment number two three zero zero
three four
okay are you ready
all right gentlemen each of you up here
if you have retained Council I'm going
to go down the line of the attorneys
capacity are you prepared to your Arena
and just refer to the record your your
client's name
see Mr stingle are you holding your
honor Demetrius Haley is my client he's
president of the corporate form of
reading with the indictment Andrew
Perry good morning honor John Perry on
behalf of Mr sudarius Bean but this time
the way the former region of the talking
to court Cleo not guilty
this is something I see back there yes
on behalf of my client Justin Smith
Charles Summers uh we uh
waveform the indictment and initially
have not guilty and happiness
so morning judge I'm happy to get your
Middle's professional waiting to be
tonight
each of your attorneys have entered
please of not guilty on your behalf
understand that despite everyone's best
effort this case may take some time or
your attorneys are going to be receiving
the discovery depending on how
voluminous the discovery is it may take
some time for the state to collect it
all to turn it over to your attorneys
for your attorneys to review that
Discovery to prepare their emotions and
prepare their case
so be patient work with your attorneys
cooperate with them meet with them go
over the discovery make sure that if
there are any delays that these delays
aren't on account of any of your actions
uh
to those also in attendance as I've
explained to the defendants this case
can take some time so we do ask for your
patience your continued patience your
continued civility in this case we
understand that there may be some
High emotions in this case but we ask
that you continue to be patient with us
everyone involved wants this case to be
concluded as quickly as possible but
it's important for you all to understand
that the state of Tennessee as well as
each one of these defendants have a
absolute right to a fair trial and I
will not allow any behavior that could
jeopardize that right
so with that being said we thank you all
for being present
uh
State understanding that there may be
some
discovery that needs to be collected we
are going to continue this case out a
little bit further to make sure the
discovery is included we're going to
reset this matter until May 1st
9 A.M
state is there anything else counter the
only other thing on behalf of the state
is to have a protective order as to each
of the defendants to allow certain
digital Discovery video evidence to be
provided
all right
thank you John
it was messy is there anything else on
behalf of your client know your honor I
believe
this morning
it's your balance him after you're fine
Mr Perry no your honor but we did file a
motion for Bill particulars so it's a
group 7c Tennessee
all right gentlemen we'll see back here
May 1st on that day and we will now
excuse the defense and their defense
Council we're asking everyone else in
the courtroom to remain in the courtroom
remain seated until you're achieved and
with regard to everybody else I would
let the court know that the family is
here
thank you
motivated
foreign
a courtroom that included of course the
family of Tyree Nichols they sat a few
rows back something like 10 12 yards
from these officers who as you saw stood
each of them the other lawyers saying
that they would plead not guilty uh
we're expecting the family of tiny
Nichols to come out of the courtroom at
some stage we'll see if in fact here
they come
questions
my family will be making a statement but
they're going to do it outside the
building
so Ben will be making a statement and
we'll be coming out to answer questions
so give me like 30 seconds with them
okay Ben and the family will be making a
statement outside the courthouse here in
a second okay and we'll be making a
statement here yet outside the
courthouse oh excited Courthouse okay
thanks very much indeed Ben Crum the
lawyer
representing the the family of Tyree
Nichols there are a number of of other
players who were inside the courtroom
not least the yeah not least the
district attorney uh for Shelby County
it's a busy day here in this uh in this
criminal Courthouse but you know uh a
front atmosphere I would say
um very difficult clearly for the family
one would imagine of Tyler Nichols we
will hear from them about their thoughts
of being in a room with the individuals
accused of murdering their son a murder
uh if it is so convicted that played out
of course in video footage footage that
they saw although tyree's mother should
be said found herself unable to watch uh
the full hour's worth of footage of
beating the last day it's something like
three minutes and of course Terry
Nichols was calling out for his mother
wasn't he when he was beaten uh I've
been to the site of where this all took
place what happened was he was arrested
pulled over for allegedly reckless
driving he managed to run away
uh and he got very close to his mother's
house he was something like
20 30 yards I would say from his
mother's house and as police were
beating him he was shouting three times
he shouted for his mom it was the final
words the tiny nickels have our sport so
clearly uh very difficult
for the family a very difficult
video to watch and I supposed to have
this all played out in public but they
want Justice
um I'll just check and see what the
arrangements are sir we're live on Sky
News what uh who are you possible Paul
Hagerman assistant district attorney
tell me Paul
um where are we in this project process
and what should take and what we've just
seen well today was their very first
court date it was their arraignment so
sort of the start of the process here
I'm sure the process will go on too long
for everybody but uh everybody's
committed to Justice and to see this
thing through
uh families back here and they attended
the court hearing and I've got to spend
some time with them for a second
they'll be making a statement later on
this morning I think they're looking for
a place to do that right now it may be
outside or or not but we'll let you know
and in terms of Investigations they
continue
yes I do yeah tell me about that we may
not have seen the last of the charges in
relation to this well yeah obviously
this this terrible crime happened in
January and it's just February uh the
investigation in this case and a lot of
other cases uh after its charge goes on
and it does there are a lot of various
agencies out investigate in this case
and they're not stopping uh today was
just the first court date for these
defendants it was their arraignment and
it's the start of the process there's
been a lot of talk about how things
moved very quickly in terms of the
criminal justice Bruce process charges
late relatively quickly why was that
important it was important in this case
I think everybody here and everybody in
Memphis and I guess everywhere I saw
that video and there needed to be a
statement made and there needs people
needed to step up and do the right thing
sooner rather than later we felt that we
felt that need and that's what we did
and it's important to have questions
answered
yeah Memphis and the whole world
needs needs to see that what's right is
done in this case and it needs to happen
sooner rather than later I was having
the five officers all involved gonna
play a role in this uh five defendants
always presents a challenge in terms of
logistics and everything I think y'all
saw that in the other day it was a
cramped courtroom and uh all that we
believe it's important that uh everybody
who took part in this criminality
everybody who did something criminals
brought to Justice in this case so
it's just part of the fight so I'm sorry
that could possibly come out I know that
uh attorney Massey put in a motion to
preserve a lot of video from Sky cop
cameras uh many of which we haven't even
seen yet
so uh it was a city that I guess
released the videos to the media and and
to everybody is Our obligation to make
sure all that video is preserved any
video I have anything to do with this
case is preserved uh and given to
defense counsel we can't release it to
the media and and stuff like that so I
know that there's been a lot of video
that's been uh
you know found in the case and taking
the case and we'll preserve it all and
it's all been reviewed and will be given
to defense counsel is it a single frame
of video is it a single frame of video
video from the scene in particular that
may or may not have been shared
um how unusual is it to have that in
this type of case and and can you talk
about that video at all you're talking
about the video released to the media
from the castle gate camera no actually
uh shot by a police officer at the scene
okay I can't comment on facts of facts
of the case that may come up you know
during the litigation it's about
releasing the video prior to this is
that hinder your case at all no it
didn't it didn't hinder our case our but
our job Remains the Same we these five
defendants are all entitled to Fair
trials uh and that's what we're gonna
that's what we're gonna go with is it a
single frame of video this suggests tidy
Nichols was driving recklessly and as I
said there's been video taken from all
over the place you know trying to get to
the bottom of uh every fact of this case
and we just have to wait and see uh sure
as it plays out anything else you'd like
to say to the Nichols family right now
well the I've gotten the pleasure to
meet the Nichols family they're
heartbroken and obviously it's a
terrible thing they lost they lost their
son they love their son they still love
their son and uh they're good people I
got to spend some time this morning and
after I leave y'all I'll be with them uh
some more I couldn't be more impressed
by Mom and the dad and the patients and
the understanding they have with us and
the statements they've made out to the
public that it's important that Tyree is
honored and in a peaceful way and in the
right way way and great people that kind
of been easy
have you ever seen any
have you ever
I'll take both both the questions uh
first investigation is ongoing so is
there a possibility of more charges of
course there is uh the general has been
my boss has been you know extremely
clear that this is step one uh and today
was just the start of the court process
and as you asked the investigation goes
on and uh we'll see where that leads us
um this
um this terrible situation I mean we all
had to watch we all had to watch that
video uh and or I think everybody's
heart went out and uh you know today's
uh court date wanted to try to get some
justice and to do what's right in this
case and we'll see it out to the end so
you spoke about the family it kind of
been easy for the family to be
uh you know unfortunately and in this
job you're dealt with you deal with
heartbreaking things after heartbreaking
things I know this is
cart before the horse may be the
understatement
this was do you want to see the or how
determined are you to see this go to
trial so is that an open court so this
is day one okay they just got an
attorney none of the attorneys have seen
the evidence yet and some of the
evidence is still being collected so I
can't comment on that is you know way
too early but what I can tell you is we
are determined to see this thing first
how long how long you've been with the
District Attorney's 21 years and you're
one second your work here and your time
how much experience have you had with
the Scorpion how much experience have
you had so we're gonna sir how much
experience
excuse me we're going to come to an end
excuse me excuse me Mr Crump uh Mr Crump
is going to make a story
well there you go a gentleman from the
attorney's office
journalists falling out with each other
a spectacle
at the end of this morning's events
um difficult difficult as you heard from
him he's been with the family difficult
for them to be in the company in the
same room as the individuals charged
with murdering their son and this is
this is a lawyer for one of the
defendants let's see if we can get
get a chat with him
I will not be taking any questions
though I know you will ask them uh you
have a brief statement I want to make on
behalf of Mr Mills we want to start out
by saying that understandably the the
nation is the nation's heart is filled
with frustration with grief due to the
death of Tyree Nichols and we understand
that
these emotions absolutely should be
channeled into demanding change in the
way that we police our communities
it's also vital that we extend these
demands to the way that we treat
minorities and people of lower incomes
in our criminal justice system
let's not forget that my client is a
black man in a courtroom in America
this is a country where black people are
incarcerated at five times the rate of
white people a country where black
people are 7.5 times more likely to be
wrongfully convicted of murder than
white people
much has been said about the ways that
the system has failed Mr Nichols I will
work tirelessly to make sure that the
system does not fail Mr Mills and that a
fair outcome is achieved
I want to remind everyone that the
resolution of this indictment
to which Mr Mills has pled not guilty
must be carried out without sympathy or
prejudice
that it must be based on the facts in
the law
and not the raw emotions that our
country is currently experiencing
Justice for Mr Nichols will not be
achieved at the expense of justice for
Mr Mills
we have a very long road of
investigation and litigation ahead of us
again I implore the public to be patient
to be cautious in judging Mr Mills we
look forward to defending him so why is
he not guilty why is he not guilty
he was he was on a group of five
officers who brutally beat Tyree Nichols
why is your client Desmond Mills Junior
not guilty why didn't he come to court
like the regular
why what is the what is the roof in that
video that your client isn't guilty
he's guilty of being in a group of five
who behave like a like a pack whose
Behavior was inhumane according to their
police chief what's up
y'all have a good day
well that was Blake Bolin the attorney
for Desmond Mills Jr one of the five who
is accused of murder and who pleads not
guilty to that let's take a walk there's
a lot going on that was the defense
attorney we've heard from
the the district attorney the
prosecutor's office and as you heard him
say investigations continue there may
well be further charges uh we're
expecting a statement from Tiny Nichols
family they're working out the logistics
of that where to speak to the media
they're talking about doing outside
let's just take a walk here to see if
that's changed and if indeed that may
take place rather closer to the
courtroom
um that's not clear yet but
um well you heard you heard the way
things are are shaping up after a brief
hearing the first Hearing in public the
first opportunity for these officers to
plead not guilty
the defense attorney says justice for
Tyree Nichols would not amount you know
would not be represented in a wrongful
conviction for his client that is the
defense narrative at this stage
um let's go around here something else
is going on
here somebody else is having a verse say
on the matter
oh it's the district attorney let's have
a let's have a listener sign in the task
of looking at these kinds of Officer
involved fatality cases for an
independent and objective review of
those as well right and and I know the
Scorpion unit
um the practices from what you've heard
yeah how troubling uh has that been for
you given some of what you're trying to
do as the new the newly elected D.A so I
think I need to be careful as a sitting
prosecutor when there are pending cases
about characterizing these kinds of
things but I think it's fair to say that
what we've learned so far
a cause for concern about an overall
culture that needs to be Revisited and I
think it really
opens up the need for a broader
conversation about police reform not
only here in Memphis and Shelby County
but I think across the country typically
about supervision within the Memphis
Police Department
we were talking about culture and
there's obviously a lack of
accountability that CJ Davis had to the
city council as far as what you're
seeing do you think there's also what do
you what is your comment about the lack
of supervision that was uh that was
lacking that night well I mean I think
Chief Davis yourself would probably
acknowledge that a lack of supervision
on that evening you know was was playing
a role in what happened and I think
whenever you have these specialized
units that you know there is a danger
that they can become
tell me about the culture and the
problems with the culture of the
Scorpion unit I mean I I think that
that's really a question better directed
to the Memphis Police folks I just think
in general sometimes these units can
become overly aggressive and they need
more supervision and that clearly was a
problem uh that evening and I think it
opens up a question a broader question
about reform now if you'll excuse me
there you go thank you for finishing I
needed to go thank you for letting him
finish you've texted me to come right
okay that was Stephen molroy the
district attorney here in Shelby County
the man a steering this criminal justice
process charges and so on charges that
we have held in court today which range
from the very top second-degree murder
murder in the second degree that means
murdering somebody inflicting injury
knowing that they will die and that is a
charge faced by by these five officers
who appeared in court today there are
other charges aggravated kidnap among
them oppression but second-degree murder
is the big one that
upon conviction
could result in a jail sentence of up to
60 years in terms of a trial that could
be many months away of course today is
the start really of the the criminal
justice process going through the courts
an arraignment hearing very brief before
Judge James Jones Jr at which you saw
the not guilty pleas from all five
defendants
the attorney speaking for them I saw one
of the attorneys
smacking his defendant on the back as he
spoke for him
um you know standing shoulder to
shoulder with their clients who are
clearly going to try to fight this
charge there's another media scrum
taking place let's see if we can get
stuck into this one I'm not entirely
sure who this is that's speaking
um
I want to fight
nobody's speaking yet possibly uh
possibly the family due to to speak to
us are the family coming out to speak to
us sir do you know
is anybody coming out to speak to us
there you go no we're just standing here
is the word for my my esteemed colleague
um you know we will hear more from uh
the family of Tyler Nichols in due
course
upsetting for them you know I was
sitting in the row behind them as they
were in court Stanley with his arm round
uh his wife Rowan well Stanley The
Stepfather of Tyler Nichols who worked
for FedEx as did Tyree Nichols himself
and you know he was described as a good
lad a good man uh not perfect said his
mother but he was damn close he worked
for FedEx used to go home to his mom's
for dinner indeed uh they reckon that
might have been where he was headed on
the night that he was stopped and
ultimately beaten to his death by these
police officers and you know we have
seen we have learned about the life of
of Tyree Nichols uh what we haven't
learned of course are the reasons behind
him being stopped in the first place the
police officers initially said it was
reckless driving that's why he was
pulled over the police chief has said
there is no evidence to to back that up
no evidence of reckless driving and
indeed one of the officers a sixth
officer president hemple in his
subsequent statement said uh that he
didn't see any reckless driving you
might have heard a question about cop
cams helicopter cams and other footage
that may be available the uh the
individual from the attorney's office he
he didn't commit on that one but it may
be that there is other footage from
other sources that will shed more light
on the death and the events leading up
to the death of Tyree Nichols we've seen
an hour's worth of footage but that
starts at the moment when the police are
on scene he's being pulled out of his
vehicle the key question is what
happened before that and that will shed
light on the Scorpion unit this
specialized unit in Memphis that was
created to tackle incidences of violent
crime it will shed light on their ammo
you know how they operated uh generally
perhaps but certainly specific to Tyree
Nichols because what we see in the video
we've all seen is instant escalation why
did that happen did Tyree trigger that
in some way was there some excuse some
reason why there was instant escalation
instant violence on the part of these
officers that in this stage remains a
mystery as as so many other aspects of
this story do actually investigations
continue we've seen five individuals
charged here
we may yet see charges
against further individuals
in due course were being summoned over
here for
somebody else appears to be speaking oh
let's have a let's have a listening
in the Press over the last what month
and a lot of those statements are
misleading about the person that he is
the domain has been nothing but a
respectful a good young man throughout
his life and on that particular night
you look at an isolated incident and try
to measure the person and so there are a
lot of statements about him as a person
that'll just flat out untrue and you
look at the level of involvement of each
individual defended and in that
particular case he was doing his job no
more no less he never struck anybody he
never did anything other than his job
right now we're in a posture that I've
never seen a person charged before
anybody knows the cause of death there's
no definitive information regarding
cause of death at all and so we got five
individuals charged with murder I
represent one and it's an honor because
at this point in time I've never seen
people
jump to conclusions about an isolated
part of a two-minute excerpt about what
was supposed to have happened on a
particular night and I
I stand by the notion that right now due
process in this matter has not taken
place properly there should be Justice
for Tyree Nichols absolutely but I also
stand by the fact that I am going to
demand Justice for tadarius being as Mr
Bean made any any statement to you
written any statement we heard from Mr
Mr Mr mean from Mr battling
is is a client wrote a statement has
your client wrote a statement
we've gone through a lot of information
there was a lot of information given on
the front end during the time that when
he was an active police officer and they
were doing their inquiries at that time
there were certain information that was
gleaned from my understanding
administratively but there's been no
follow-up statements as of right now so
what in that video what in that video
tells us that you're you're a client
is innocent so there is being according
to the video was seen apprehending a
person after
it's murder
you saw the sign what in that video
tells us that your client tadario has
been is innocent say that it won't say
that once again yeah we've all seen
people that are part of the press that
are saying we've all seen we've all seen
the video what in that video tells us
that your client tadarius is innocent
today is being never touched never
touched him in any way striking him
period to Darius being tadarius being
has the ability as a law enforcement
officer to make a lawful arrest based
off of a call coming in and so at this
time that's where we're standing right
now that that tadarius being was doing
his job at that time and he never and he
never struck him and there has been no
no information that we have seen as of
right now that indicates that there's a
that there's any sort of information
that that we can rely on to say that
it's murder why didn't he intervene why
didn't he intervene and stop his
colleagues piecing a man to death I
think if you hear I think you hear his
voice consistently so things uh sit up
man so you can get air Etc and things
like that I think you I think you hear I
think you hear him consistently saying
that and to Darius being today to Darius
being at no point in time did anything
that would be different from a person
who's doing his job he didn't stop his
colleagues killing him on them I'm sorry
he didn't stop his colleagues killing
him man so why didn't he intervene and
say enough stop
that I want to hear his duty as a police
officer I'm gonna do something rare have
you ever made an arrest no have you ever
have you ever jumped out of a car trying
to apprehend somebody who you think
might have committed a carjacking a
robbery a raper kidnapping have you ever
done that I've never stood by and let
four of my colleagues kill him and if a
person gets called on a scene you have a
duty as a police officer to respond if
you're not on that he had a duty to stop
a man being killed surely be absolutely
clear Mr Bean was not Mr B Mr Bean was
not on the first scene so he don't know
yeah the second scene is what Tony
Nichols was beaten I'm sorry does he
regret any of his actions that night I
think at this point he probably regrets
being a Memphis police officer on that
night because had he not been he
wouldn't have been called to do his job
is there anything he'd like to say to
the family of Tyree Nichols
I I I won't say I won't say what Mr Bean
says regarding the family I will say
that from my heart regarding the family
anytime you have a young man that dies
it's sad and it's and it's a horrible
thing and we don't want that to happen
so but as far as where we are as of
right now we're trying to see whether or
not a person can get Justice the way
that anybody else can and I and that's
my job
I think at the time that at the
conclusion of making the arrest from my
understanding there were people that
were on the scene that are professional
health renderers from my understanding
so to to say that uh yes ma'am I watched
the video go ahead
okay so how many hours is it we have to
turn everything over I'm sorry ma'am
there's 20 hours essentially a video
have you seen all of that no nobody's
seen it we'll see it at the same time
when they're really emotion to preserve
all of the video from the route all
right we want that yes we're joining
that motion I think one has been filed
if you're going to enjoy that motion
quick how much more video do you think
can't be collected obviously uh it's a
video that could possibly uh tell more
of this story of this side Chase on foot
between Tyree Nichols and the five
officers or at least two or three of
those officers do we know if one the
your
client Mr one of the officers chasing it
after Tyree Nichols on foot
um I apologize I just can't hear the
whole question I'm sorry just say it one
more time
your client Mr tadarius Bean is one of
the officers possibly chasing Tyree
Nichols on foot or during this during
the second scene my client is on the
second scene
going to the second scene do we know if
he's one of the officers chasing
there's a suggestion that there's a
connection somehow between Tyree Nichols
and the officers involved they they knew
each other and there was a reason why
those officers might have wanted to
inflict violence on Tidy Knuckles
they're rumors can you comment on that I
haven't seen anything to suggest any
truth to any of that at all
I haven't seen any of that what's your
name son John Keith Perry and you
represent tadarius Kim yes sir all right
thank you all right thank you thank you
do you mind if I grab you just for a
second
foreign
and
you know the picture is building as to
how this defense case for all five
will will be constructed clearly you get
a sense of every man for themselves
every man
defending his own role in that
particular situation and he was talking
about his client tadarius being saying
that essentially he wasn't an aggressive
player as smart as these are my words in
that uh that beating scenario the
question I asked him and it's a question
it was the question why he was instantly
fired in the first instance from the
police force that as an officer he had a
duty to protect the public there was a
duty to intervene when a man was
sustaining fatal injuries none of the
five did that on the evidence of that
video nobody stepped in and said stop
and that is a key part of the problem
here and we'll see how the prosecution
case pans out but I would imagine it
will be around that
that argument that five individuals
acted in concert and that you can't pick
any any one individual off from that
Central charge that they acted as a unit
and therefore are culpable as a unit but
the defense clearly will take shape
along five different individual paths
thank you so much for all that extra
detail there and as you say as you said
earlier certainly all five of those
defendants
um weren't seen in that video to appear
to to offer any Aid to Tyree Nichols
after he was injured and lying on the
ground we will cross back to you very
shortly James because of course we're
waiting to hear from Tyree Nichols
family and their lawyer Ben Crump
outside the courthouse that shot there
ready and waiting for their arrival and
James I understand is going to
reposition for us outside the courtroom
so we'll cross back to him very shortly
but in the meantime we're going to bring
in our two guests Jasmine Rand and
Randolph McLaughlin who are here to
commentate on this case for us uh
Jasmine to you first all five of these
former Memphis police officers have
pleaded not guilty to the murder of
Tyree Nichols today in that very brief
court hearing there in Memphis Yuri
reaction to these not guilty pleas by
all five of these former officers
that really shocked that they pled not
guilty I expected them to plead not
guilty
um you know what I am shocked by is the
statements of their counsel afterward I
don't think that was a smart move on
behalf of their Council
um it was particularly Brave of the
attorneys to stand up there and say that
their client never hid or struck or came
in contact with Tyree Nichols
um at all especially admitting he's not
even seen the video footage or all of
the video footage that's involved in the
case
and to hear them talk about their denial
of due process what about Tyree Nichols
due process where was those officers
concerned with the due process of Tyree
Nichols not to be summarily executed on
the streets in Memphis that night
yeah let's just bring in Randolph for
his reaction as well Randolph was really
interesting as Jasmine just um alluded
to that that we heard from those two
defense attorneys for two of uh the
defendants to Darius Bean his uh defense
attorney claimed that we don't yet know
the cause of death and that due process
in this matter has not taken place your
reaction to that
I thought look at first matter defense
lawyers have a difficult job in a case
like this each individual defendant has
to be found guilty or not guilty based
upon their individual conduct understood
but I agree with Jasmine the comments
that these men made trying to wrap
themselves in this mantle of due process
comparing themselves to Young
African-American males who were caught
up in the criminal justice system
prosecuted and thrown in jail for hardly
any evidence many times
these men are not those young kids these
men were trained police officers and
when the when the lawyer from Mr Bean
said he was just doing his job well what
was his job chasing an unarmed man for
what reason and and what was his job
when he stood by and if you watch the
video you'll see at various points
officers holding Tyree Nichols up so
other officers could beat him could kick
him like he was a like he was a pinball
in a game
I mean it's it's almost like
unbelievable to me I understand their
job but you know what they need to keep
their mouth shut and just do their job
in the courtroom because if they think
that going to the public to change
anyone's Minds based upon what we have
seen that's a Fool's errand they need to
focus on their jobs and and not try and
make
themselves a victim firstly a victim
what was their job that night to arrest
a young black man and beat him to death
if that's what they did allegedly was
that their job that's big Bank these
same officers this same unit had been
caught in a number of incidents like
this
beating up people dragging them out of
cars cursing at people that's what this
unit did the only difference here is
they went too far they didn't know to
stop the beat down before they killed
him so I'm sorry yes it's going to be a
long process yes there'll be a lot of
Discovery and more videotapes will come
out understood but here's the bottom
line if you want to change police
Behavior you've got to change the law
regulating police conduct that's what
you have to do here in the United States
we have a George Floyd law that's trying
to get passed in Congress to make
policing more fair and transparent can't
get it out of Congress so here's what I
say the state of Miss the state of
Tennessee needs to take that law and
adopt it so that all of us can start to
be
securing our homes securing Our Lives
you shouldn't be subject to death
because you quote unquote recklessly
drove look at the way the officers
approached him as soon as the car stops
they're cursing at him they're yelling
at him they're snatching him up and he
says to them why are you guys doing all
this to me I mean it's clear he doesn't
know what's going on and his his
reaction of running away that was a
natural human reaction in his mind
understandably these men were going to
kill him or certainly cause him serious
bodily harm so he was doing what your
your adrenaline tells you to do blight
or fight he didn't fight back he never
raised a hand against these Gods he was
trying to get home to his mother and
they killed him for it I'm sorry this
isn't outrage so yes they have a right
to a defense yes they have a right to
Due Process here's an interesting
question this case is going to be tried
in Memphis and I know Memphis is a
predominantly African-American City now
so are they going to be willing to try
this case before a jury of Memphis
residents maybe that's why they're
making these I think ridiculous public
statements wrapping themselves in the
mantle of civil rights lawyers that's
what we do that's not what criminal
defense lawyers do when their officers
are accused of killing an unarmed black
man
period
yeah Randolph really interesting that
you mentioned that the two defense
attorneys we just heard from there quite
surprising that they were willing to
comment on camera at this stage and as
you say portray these former police
officers essentially as victims
themselves Jasmine because of course in
court in trial uh all they will care
about are the facts of this case and
certainly the evidence is clear in that
body cam footage you can't recreate what
happened it's there for the jury to see
for themselves
yeah it's there for the jury to see for
themselves
um in this case so much of this incident
was captured on footage they're going to
see the images of the officers holding
him up so other officers can beat him
they're going to see
um that the officer's actions took the
life of Tyree Nichols and they're going
to hear testimony that Tyree Nichols was
running home to his mother's house
that's all he was trying to do he wasn't
fighting back he wasn't hitting anybody
he he didn't break any laws he was
running home to his mother's house and
they beat him down in the streets of
Memphis 20 to 30 yards away from his
mother's house as he cried out asking
her for help that's what the jury is
going to hear and I believe when the
jury hears that they're going to convict
all of those officers of second-degree
murder and Randolph of course um what do
you make of the fact that they behaved
in this way towards Tyree Nichols
knowing that they were wearing body cams
what does that tell you
but frankly that's the most shocking
thing well the most one of the more
shocking things when when police
officers resisted the use of body cams
when they were first being put out
because they were concerned that you
know you wouldn't see the whole story
and police work is very rough and
violent and you get the wrong idea so
they didn't want to wear them at first
but guess what started to happen good
police officers wearing body cams were
exonerated when their conduct was being
evaluated because the body cam you know
proved that they were innocent of any
crimes but here I don't see how these
officers in any shape fashion or form
could believe that what they were doing
especially in the second incident when
they captured him and are beating him
like a runaway slave
how they could think this was okay but
what it tells me is they did they
thought that what they were doing was
okay that it was nothing wrong you could
hear them saying things like I want to
stop him down
it it boggles my mind but to be frank
the only difference between what
happened here and what happened in
George Floyd's case and what happened in
Eric Garner who was killed in in Staten
Island here in New York when an officer
used to choke hold allegedly
is that you have video counts but often
the offices when there's no video engage
in similar acts of brutality and then
engage in another police practice called
test the line where they make up a story
and they all support each other so
that's the only difference so when we
say does this shock me no it doesn't
shock me at all I've done it I've
handled enough cases of police officers
shooting and killing unarmed individuals
who had a mental health crisis in their
homes so that doesn't Shock Me
what shocked the public is that they're
seeing
it in real time what happened to George
Floyd that's why they had that outrage
and that outcline here I think we're
correct it's not happening at the same
level because the response of the local
officials has been so different than
anything I have ever seen in any part of
this United States in this country it
was quick it was immediate and it was
definitive and they released the
videotape quickly so we could all see it
so I I think that as they say
what happened in Memphis and what is
happening in Memphis
is a blueprint it's a model for how we
should handle these cases in the future
because Swift Justice is still justice
justice delayed is still Justice denied
now Randolph Jasmine
um there is a bit of movement outside
the courtroom uh I will interrupt our
interview and conversation when we hear
from the family and from bankrupt their
lawyer very shortly but just in the
meantime uh Jasmine just further to what
Randolph was saying there you know
there's also in that body cam footage it
shows that when Tyree Nichols is lying
on the ground badly injured clearly uh
not well no officer did a welfare check
on him or offered him any Aid how how
much is that going to be further damning
detail in this trial
you know as Professor McLaughlin pointed
out so much of this is cultural and
endemic to policing in America and you
know just like he said it's not shocking
to him it's not shocking to me it's
shocking to the public because they
don't see these cases on a daily basis
like we do but I very commonly see these
type of cases we just don't always have
cameras and so what we often see in
these cases where first there's this
engaging in police brutality then there
is a failure to surrender Medical Aid
um I think that that is going to add
insult to injury when the jury sees that
they're also going to see that there was
a clear intention to inflict harm
because there was no desire to save his
life um from them or from the the fire
department
um uh employees who arrived on the scene
either and so I think that that is going
to further inflame the jury
um and you know maybe lead to some
stiffer sentencing from the judge
now Randolph of course we're waiting to
hear from the family and from their
lawyer now it's so reminiscent of so
many other cases that we've heard before
I met Ben Crump a number of times in
Minneapolis when he was representing
George Floyd's family and here we are
again hearing the same calls for justice
the same calls for a form from the same
people like Ben Crump from Reverend Al
Sharpton what do we need for change
what we need we need less I'll be honest
demonstrations are important brings out
the public but we need less
demonstrations and more Civic engagement
what do I mean by that if activists are
really concerned about this issue and
it's not just the the police brutality
incident
of the day and we all focus on it we
need to get involved at the local level
with the police with the folk with the
local prosecutors and with local
legislatures here's a phenomenon how do
we hire police officers I think we don't
test them appropriately I'll give you an
example I used to work in a program
where we train service animals service
dogs to work with veterans and disabled
people and we had to determine as
trainers whether that dog had a predator
Instinct what does that mean that when a
Scrabble ran by they'd go and Chase the
squirrel so if the dog had a predator
Instinct then we couldn't use them in
the program so similar if I can
determine by observing an uh an animal
whether or not they have a predator
Instinct can I do the same thing
observing human behavior because here's
the question you need to know as hiring
a police officer does that officer have
a propensity to use violence to solve
problems the police officers sometimes
have to use Force no question about it
when when violence is needed and
violence is present yes violence will be
used under stood but not every situation
I'm just going to interrupt ever ever so
quickly just to just to update our
viewers anyone tuning in now to let them
know what their what they're seeing on
screen uh that is a an image of the door
at the courthouse in Memphis and we are
awaiting uh Ben Crump the lawyer for
Tyree Nichols family and his family who
are due to appear any moment now uh
before they give a statement outside uh
court and that camera is our
correspondent and camera crew there in
Memphis awaiting Ben Crump and Tyree
Nichols family to try and grab a word
with them uh before they go to the
microphones to make that statement so we
will cut into that as soon as they
appear but just in the meantime Jasmine
there was a sixth police officer there
that day who's been fired from Memphis
police force but not charged tell us
about them
so that is Officer press and Hemphill
um you know first of all he is a white
officer and so it's certainly concerning
that you know the only white officer who
was involved in this incident that we
know of so far who was there on the
scene and on the ground has not been
arrested
um we know that he tasered Tyree Nichols
we know that he engaged in beating him
without any justification when he was
first pulled out of the vehicle he made
comments such as directing people to
stomp his his ass I don't want to you
know say that on camera
um and then we also know that he he lied
and falsified information and evidence
during the investigation
um and so he needs to be charged with
second-degree murder just like these
other officers have been charged you
know I I really want to go back because
I've been working alongside Ben Crump
for 15 years now I actually began
working with Ben as a law student and
then when I graduated became the head of
his civil rights Division and one of my
first cases ever was the Trayvon Martin
case and I will say we have progressed
as a society where we are finally
getting arrests at where we are count
getting accountability for these cases
we are getting convictions we are able
to recover monetary damages
um for victims of police brutality but
we're not where we want to be where do
we want to be what do Ben and I want to
see we want to save lives we don't want
to be on the other end of this
responding to another case where another
unarmed young black man or woman is
another victim of police brutality we
want to be on the Forefront of this
changing the culture of policing so that
we are not responding to death that we
are saving lives
uh and Randolph I thought from you if I
may or five of these police officers
involved in this incident uh with Tyree
Nichols all charged with his murder have
pleaded not guilty today
what do you make of that and and what do
you think we'll hear in terms of the
defense that they will try and present
in court
that's their right I've yet to see a
criminal defendant ever and I've done
criminal defense work I handled murder
cases myself
I've never seen an author a criminal
defendant walked into court the very
first time
sorry sorry Randolph do continue
yeah I've never seen a criminal
defendant walk into court the very first
day and say guilty no one does that so
it's their right the criminal process
has to run its course and I respect that
process and I and it will I mean there's
no allegation no suggestion he's on my
side that that anything violating their
due process rights has occurred or will
occur so it's a long haul what I think
these officers are going to do
eventually is turn on each other
eventually because the ones who have the
the lower charges or the lower less
culpability because they didn't engage
in the final acts of Killing Him
etc those officers will start to try and
exonerate themselves that's what's going
to happen and they may start pointing
their fingers at others the the
prosecutor was asked are you talking
about plea deals with anybody not yet
it's too early but they may they may
because if you do a plea deal with some
lower level officer to turn against the
others and he starts telling you things
that you didn't know otherwise that's
valuable testimony and it's done often
you you take a defending you cut them a
deal and have them turn on the others
that could happen here yeah that's very
interesting Jasmine your thoughts on
that Randolph uh they're predicting uh
that these five offices will turn on any
on each other through the course of this
trial and our correspondent in Memphis
was reporting earlier that all five of
these officers officers are said to be
remorseful and regretful about what
happened that day but I guess one of the
questions that prosecutors will ask is
well what did you think would happen
when five of you uh were essentially
carrying out that behavior on on a
single individual
yeah and so I think I absolutely agree
with Professor McLaughlin that the
officers will begin to turn on each
other and I think you even heard some of
that today
um I think there was the implication in
the statements from some of the
attorneys that well my guy didn't do
anything I don't think my guy um you
know landed a punch or landed a blow so
why is he being criminally charged and I
think that we're going to continue to
hear that Dynamic develop
um and that's certainly a common
strategy that um that defendants use
when they're defending themselves
against criminal allegations so I expect
to see that as well
and Jasmine what more can you tell me on
this uh so-called scorpion unit that all
five of these former police officers
were members of this this uh supposedly
an elite unit that was set up in 2021 to
tackle crime in Memphis they have a
pretty bad reputation this unit tell us
more
yes they do have a pretty bad reputation
and when you create these units one of
the problems is you're actually creating
a mob mentality you are rewarding people
for going out and being quote unquote
tough on crime and you're rewarding them
for engaging for getting you know drugs
off of the street
um you know sometimes people get
rewarded for for officers get rewarded
oftentimes for shooting people what
officers are almost never rewarded for
is de-escalating situations and that's
one of the biggest problems I think we
have in our police force is there is no
reward for say for for saving lives in
that way for de-escalating situations
and so I think that there has to be an
award system and incentivizing officers
for de-escalating and being responsible
and intervening when they see other
officers using unlawful Force like we
saw in The Tyree Nichols matter not one
of those officers intervened and that's
one of the biggest issues that we have
is that nobody stopped that that brutal
beating to try to save his life
yeah Randolph your thoughts on on this
as well this so-called scorpion unit uh
supposedly Elite unit these five former
officers were part of uh they were known
for being violent in Memphis and that
unit has now been disbanded what are
your thoughts on this why was an elite
unit like this carrying out traffic stop
I wouldn't call this an elite unit I
would call it a mob unit because that's
what they acted like like a mob and
stopping people and just dragging them
out of cars but these units have been
used by cities New York City itself did
this they create these units because of
a high crime situations and we have to
deal take the guns off the street and we
have to be a little more aggressive in
those situations okay that's a notion
here in New York City we had a unit
called the street crimes unit and they
would want roam the city and unmarked
cars and jump out of cars and confront
people well one night they confronted a
man named Amadou Diallo an African
immigrant in the Bronx and according to
the police officers he pulled out his
black wallet and pointed at them while
they had their guns out now that's just
crazy talk
they shot him 41 41 times
42 times dead and then after they killed
him they went into his apartment to look
for things what were they looking for
evidence of crime no doubt drugs guns to
basically smear this man to say this is
why we killed him he's a bad egg so
after that incident that unit was
disbanded same thing happening here
was the unit and this thing think of the
name scorpions what do scorpions do
they're killers they sting you and kill
you that's what they do why would you
put that in the mentality of the office
we go down and sting and maybe in this
case kill no no no these units need to
be disbanded because the problem is it
encourages the warrior mentality there
are two types of officers that we have
one are called Guardian officers your
car you can't get into your car you call
the police someone's died in your home
family member you called the police they
come and they help you that's the
guardian or caretaker function the
warrior function that's the street
crimes unit that's the Emergency
Services SWAT team they dress in
military gear and they go out and and
literally on a wartime mentality and in
some situations you need that if you've
got a terrorist holding up in a building
with a bomb you need a war you to come
in the problem is we don't identify when
the police officers are coming into the
units who are we dealing with is it a
warrior mentality person who's going to
use violence as the first means of
defense or is it someone who has a more
caretaker role who will engage in
de-escalation conversation here's what
this case really is about bottom line
it's about excessive force police
officers are empowered to use Force when
required but it's like force for like
force so if someone's resisting arrest
violently put my hands on that person
I'm just going to interrupt and jump in
for a sec let's just have a listen to
Ben Crump
and they're going to leave then you're
live on Sky News just uh very quickly
yeah I will watch your news conference
what did you think of this morning's
events they're not guilty please
what do you think what do you think
I think
as Rovan said before
she got to this courtroom she came here
because she wanted them to look her in
her face
and none of them had the courage to look
her in her face we'll talk at the press
conference thank Trump uh the law for
the family of Tidy Nichols um you heard
from there
the mother's challenge today was Luke me
in the eye to these five individuals
accused of murdering her son none of
them
as you heard Ben Crump said did he's a
man he's the family the lawyer for the
family A man often described as the
Attorney General of Black America you
might recognize him from the cases of
George Floyd Brianna Taylor and others
the family are going to hold a news
conference as he said in about three or
four minutes we'll bring that to you
live we're on floor five of Shelby
Courthouse that will be outside
downstairs and we will hear from
uh Rodney and from rovon the parents of
Tyree Nichols the parents who were yards
from him as he was beaten to death he
was trying to get to his mother's home
and the last words we heard from Tyree
Nichols were his shouts three shouts for
his mom
uh and you know that's the reason that
she has not been able to watch the video
of her son's death let's keep an eye on
that door just know that's where the
family are with their lawyers
they'll come out and expand on their
thoughts about
what was quite a highly charged court
hearing it lasted around 10 15 minutes
but significant significant in terms of
Criminal Justice because these five
individuals were entering their not
guilty pleas but
just in terms of the interaction it was
significant hugely significant for the
family of course for the first time
they were in the same room
with the five individuals accused of
murdering
their son
there is some movement behind those as
the family are obviously on the way out
to uh to deliver that news conference
very shortly
Rodney as I say tiny Nichols stepfather
ruvonne
his mother who described her son as a
good man not perfect she said but damn
near and
we're gonna head outside though just to
uh to relocate and for that news
conference which will be in a matter of
minutes and we'll hear the thoughts of
the family of Tyree Nichols in full so
stay tuned for that
James thanks very much we'll cross back
to you as soon as there's any movement
from Tyree Nichols family and lawyer
there but let's in the meantime just
continue speaking to our guests Jasmine
Randon Randolph McLaughlin thanks very
much indeed for staying with us as our
correspondent uh in Memphis was just a
detailing there you know so many of the
details of this case are just so
upsetting the fact that Tyree Nichols
was shouting for his mum appeared to be
running towards her house to escape
um you know the actions of those five
police officers
um Jasmine to you if I may I know that
you were involved in the George Floyd
case
um and certainly um in Minneapolis many
tried to argue that Derek Chauvin who of
course was found guilty of the murder of
George Floyd you know was it was a bad
apple
but in in this case with these five
police officers from Memphis at the Bad
Apple Theory doesn't doesn't stick
anymore does it
I mean I don't think the Bad Apple
Theory stuck even in in the instance of
George Floyd because what we saw was
something very similar we saw multiple
officers you know Derek Chauvin is the
one that had his knee on his neck but
what about those other officers that
stood there and did nothing and watched
him die watched him die in real time
um and so we're seeing the same thing
play out again on television where this
time it was different officers who were
inflicting the brutal beating all at the
same time but nobody was intervening
nobody was intervening to stop it and so
unless the culture of policing changes
we're going to see keep seeing this
happen
um I do think that with increasing
criminal consequence levied against
police police officers for killing
unarmed black men and women we are going
to see
um I'm hoping that we're going to see a
decrease with police brutality but as
you know Attorney Benjamin Crump has
said this is the blueprint we have to
see Swift Justice each time this happens
in America we have to see an immediate
arrest in immediate transparency the
release of the videos and and the
accountability
um and so you know what we're seeing I
hope will continue to become a blueprint
and I do expect to see other arrests as
this case evolves as well
uh and Randolph um just as Jasmine was
saying there you know describing the
deeply rooted systemic issues as she
sees it uh in policing in America when
it comes to brutality and violence
towards uh Black Americans how has how
has this how have these systemic
problems been allowed to proliferate and
grow like this what's what's behind it
well what
in a word
it's what we expect
the the perception of young black men in
the media on the news every day every
country every city in this country you
turn on the local news you'll see some
young black man getting arrested for
some crime of some sort so the
perception becomes young black men are
dangerous and they're criminals so when
the police encounter them the police
says the police officer also a part of
society seeing the same news accounts
hearing from fellow offices their first
perception is this man's dangerous he's
a criminal he may hurt me because I also
say this police officers don't get up in
the morning and say let me go and kill
someone Randolph I'm going to jump in
Randolph McLaughlin Jasmine Rand thank
you both so much let's listen into Ben
Crump the lawyer for Tyree Nichols
family
thank you
give us just a few minutes we're waiting
for a couple other
media Representatives set up
what's happening
for anyone just tuning in this is uh the
live scene in Memphis outside the
courthouse there where there's been an
arraignment hearing a plea hearing today
for five former Memphis police officers
charged with a murder of 29 year old
Tyree Nichols which of course is a case
that shocked so many people in America
around the world after body cam footage
was made public showing officers
stopping Tyree Nichols in a traffic stop
and pulling him out of his car and
beating him he later died in hospital
and those five now former Memphis police
officers have appeared in court today
charged with Tyree Nichols murder
they've all pleaded not guilty and we
are looking at that live scene there
outside the courthouse
with the family lawyer there Ben Crump
with the brown hat on and Tyree Nichols
mother who we expect to hear from very
shortly as well she is there and of
course a very upsetting detail from this
case where Tyree Nichols Was Heard
shouting for his mother as he was being
beaten up by these police officers on
the 7th of January that traffic stopped
captured on their body cams that footage
made public and certainly it's reignited
a lot of anger in America over police
brutality towards black Americans and
let's just listen in now to bankrupt the
lawyer and the family of time everyone
ready okay
uh good morning
I'm Attorney Ben Crump along with
attorney Tony rominucci
judge Ernestine Doris and attorney Van
Turner who's also the president of the
NAACP chapter here in Memphis Tennessee
Kareem Alima investigator and our legal
team we have the honor of representing
the family of Tyree Nichols present with
us is his family members as in
particularly
his mother
rovonne Wells and his father Rodney
Wells who would give very brief
statements this morning
in the aftermath of the arraignment of
the five officers that
have been indicted for the murder
of Tyree Nichols
also it's important to note
that
this was very emotional
and there were a lot of things that were
not said in the courtroom today
in the
proceeding but it was a very informative
day as we move closer to Justice
and our legal team and the family of
Tyree Nichols wish to Express gratitude
to district attorney Steve mulroy uh
Paul Hagerman and the entire District
Attorney's team uh who is charged with
Prosecuting this matter on behalf of
Tyree Nichols as they do with every
citizen in this jurisdiction
we are again
relieved that they have given
information to try to dispel some of
these rumors and innuendo that we keep
being bombarded about
that somehow this was something personal
no we uh where
that there were photographs that were
taken and none of them were
sent to all of these rumors that are out
there
in the social media world
the family is dealing with enough
grieving the death of Tyree and their
Brave fight for justice then to have to
deal with all these salacious rumors I
know in George Floyd they had to deal
with them talking about
Chauvin and I knew somebody who George
Floyd knew and that was the reason he
kept his knee on his neck and then in
both them jeans case who was killed in
the apartment by the white police woman
they alleged that they were having some
counter Affair which all were bogus and
untrue and just like with Tyree Nichols
all these rumors that are circulating
are bogus and untrue because we have the
text messages the prosecutors have been
able to verify exactly who those
pictures were sent to and so what we
want to remain laser focused on
is getting Justice for Tyree Nichols and
being able to define the legacy of Tyree
Nichols and the people
who are most appropriate to do that is
his mother in their family
so you're going to hear from
Rodney Wells uh and then we're gonna
introduce uh Miss rovonne Wells to talk
about how
they felt and
why they had to be here today
for this arraignment
of the former Memphis police officers
who are charged with murdering
Tyree Nichols and I I think it's
important to note that
even though we want everybody to get due
process
we are we are champions for Equal
justice and due process
but as police chief Davis said judge
dose
it's important that we take Swift action
it's important that we move swiftly
towards justice so we don't want there
to be any unnecessary delays in
Prosecuting this case
with respect to everybody having their
day in court
those officers get to have their day in
court but my God
Ravine Wells and Rodney Wells get to
have their day in court and we don't
want this to be
fair but we got video
when people in our community do
something on video it don't take a long
time to prosecute them writer turn to
Turner that's right it don't take a long
time and so first you were here for Mr
Rodney Wells the father of Tyree Nichols
hi everybody my name is Rodney Wales
uh I had to be here today
to make sure that Justice gets done for
our son
this is a glorious day this is the
beginning of the process
so the statement's going to be very
short
and I'm just glad to be here our
family's glad to be here and I
appreciate everybody coming out
thank you Mr Wells and now you will hear
from uh tyree's mother Miss rovon Wells
good afternoon everyone
um thank you for being here
as my husband stated
this is the beginning of the process
we're going to be here at every court
day
so that they can know that we're here
they need to
I don't know I feel it's funny because I
feel very numb right now I feel very
numb and I'm waiting for
this nightmare basically that I'm going
through right now I'm waiting for
somebody to wake me up right I'm really
waiting for somebody to wake me up but I
also know that's not going to happen
okay I know my son is gone
I know I'll never see him again
but we have to start this process of
Justice right now and I want each and
every one of those police officers
to be able to look me in the face that
they haven't done that yet they couldn't
even do that today they didn't even have
the courage to look at me in my face
after what they did to my son
so they're going to see me at every
court date everyone exactly and um until
we get Justice for my son
amen hello and so yes and and
note the choice of words that robots
used
as uh she told judge Dawson us
they didn't have the courage to look me
in my face
not
dignity to looking in my face because
when you look at the video there was no
dignity there
but they didn't even have the courage to
look at her in her face and that's what
she came to the court room to
see today them booked her and her face
eye to eye how could you do this to my
son
and they didn't okay
no what are you finished yes okay all
right we'll take a few questions what
did you think when you heard the words
not guilty well sir they're going to say
that you know that's a procedure that
everyone's gonna say and do I'm gonna
leave it up to this the District
Attorney's office and to get them
prosecuted and everything and then
they'll find them not guilt they'll find
them guilty I should say so them saying
they're not guilty that's a preliminary
thing everybody's gonna say that
um and I was expecting it so it wasn't
nothing new okay
um judge Ernestine Doris is gonna make a
remarks before you before we continue
the Questions jazz Doris says uh retired
judge Ernestine hunt Dorset and that's
not
get me out of place because I want you
to know that the process is the process
and I'm I'm about transparency so that's
the first thing I had to tell you I was
retired but
it's good to see the country and the
state still interested in what's
happening in our community and
especially in the prosecution of this
case because this case is the case
that's pretty much going to be a
Cornerstone you know when the builders
start rejecting stones but this is going
to be a Cornerstone that the builders
would not be able to reject
so I that is what I I see and
the process is yeah can you lay out what
you think the next year will be in terms
of this case so we the next hearing is
in May and then what is the next well I
I can only do it I mean I've been a
trial lawyer and I can tell you the
process it's not as Swift it's not as
Swift as the indictment but the
indictment was the most important thing
to get the wheels of Justice to truly
roll and so this is going to be
processed and it's not necessarily going
to be held up by trying to slow the
process it's just how time is and so
most criminal cases don't come to trial
and I'm assuming this is going to go to
trial
that uh can't tell you how long but it's
not going to be at the end
Steve uh we know liking George Floyd's
case in the monster
that there may be federal charges fought
here and so we want there to be four
Justice uh and so as we look at the
process on the state we understand just
like in George Floyd there may be
federal charges contemplated that may be
announced and then they would take a
parallel course but we know in George
Floyd's tragic killing that those
officers were prosecuted in the year so
the hope is that
we have a blueprint going forward on all
these tragedies before we take any of
the questions of attorney Van Turner
would you like to give her a mark yeah
we again want to thank uh
robon Wells for her courage Mr Rodney
Wells for his courage it takes a lot
to sit there in the courtroom in the
face individuals who took actions that
they did not have to take nothing that
evening
that we saw that you saw provoke them to
do what they did to Tyree Nichols and
here we have a family
we have a son
I just lost the father
and we just
um we feel their pain and we're going to
be here with them throughout the way
but let's also understand that this case
is going to be a landmark decision but
it also needs to lead to policy how do
we stop this from happening again
the state needs to pass the Tyree
Nichols police Reform Act amen we need
the governor to sign the bill the
governor Billy needs to stand up for
this family we want the thoughts we want
the prayers but we want action amen we
want this bill passed right now The
Tyree Nichols police Reform Act we want
them to withdraw the bill to get rid of
cler the Citizen Law Enforcement review
board is what we have that's the
citizens eyes over law enforcement right
the police can't continue to police
themselves
so if we are really serious about
Justice for Tyree we want to make sure
that there's a swift prosecution and
that these guys serve the time for what
they did and we want to make sure that
Swift action at the Tennessee
legislature we're passing this bill and
we want them to immediately withdraw the
bill that would undo clear right now
today yes we want them to withdraw their
bill because that's the citizens eyes
over law enforcement we're going to
continue to pray for for this family and
we're going to continue to say justice
for Tyree
thank you so much uh president Turner
for your leadership
you good I'm good okay Ms ravan since
January 7th your life has been
completely
the world has been watching your family
but you've responded with Grace and
compassion that you owe no one so I
wanted to ask you what's holding you
together right now and what is
sustaining of you and Mr Wells you know
the only thing I could tell you is the
problem is the prayer I have
everybody I have people reached out to
me from all over the world I have
received sympathy cards from
people that I don't even know
people are praying for our family
God is what's holding us up in the fact
that
again I have to always keep in mind that
my son was sacrificed for the greater
good that's what's holding me up and
that's what's keeping me together and
the fact that I do have three other
children that I have to stay strong for
because if I break down then they're
going to break down so me being a mother
I have to say as strong as I can for my
other children
amen thank you yes ma'am and then we'll
come to you
[Music]
certainly the video speaks for itself
photographs that we're taking from the
scene
at least she
dared with other people
do you know who those photographs were
shared uh uh apparently this isn't the
first time that that particular officer
has done this but we just want to dispel
the rumors that the family were being
bombarded with uh and they didn't want
to have to deal with that additional
trauma and drama so we wanted to clear
that up once and fall we do not but they
know yeah
no we we don't have to toxicology yet
but we feel confident that Tyree was not
under any account of uh intoxication or
anything like that you know Miss Revan
and Rodney they know Tyree what kind of
person he was who Tyree was was what you
saw in that video why everybody else was
escalating it using excessive force
Tyree was de-escalating trying to do
everything in his power to remain calm
that's who Tyree Nichols was exactly
actually that also I piggybacking off of
that we know that the incident report
that was authored that night does not
line up exactly with reality one of
those quotes from that report says that
the officers came in contact with you
that you're that you thought your son's
drink might have been spite is that was
that taken out of context something
taken out of context and so we the pro
I'm sorry the prosecutor will deal with
all of that yeah I can't go any further
with it but it was taken out of context
completely out of context completely
taken out of context we think that from
the beginning it was a conspiracy to
cover up this murder that's right
share the city has said that it's going
to release more video and recording are
they going to offer you to see those
first yes they did say that we don't
know when but they said they would got a
respect for the family they would let
them see and hear the videos they should
Preston hample the sixth officer who was
at the scene when tyvee was first off
she faced charges well certainly Miss
revonne Wales is asking that question
and so it is our hope that every officer
who had anything to do with the death of
her son will be held accountable and we
will leave that for the prosecutors what
is the timing of any civil litigation
against the city of Memphis well we're
trying to get the completed uh autopsy
uh report in our hands but we will be
seeking for justice for Tyree Nichols
that is Criminal culpability
silver accountability and as my
co-counselor van Turner said policy we
want legislative action because getting
Justice for Tyree isn't about just
having accountability of these officers
it's about trying to prevent anybody
else from being killed in this manner
one last question ma'am
no I didn't see the text they told us
about the text and they told us that all
of this stuff that is rampant out there
on social media is completely untrue
it's bogus and they know that the text
messages who they went to had nothing to
do with all this stuff that you all have
been hearing on social media and some of
you have reported and the only reason
that they thought it was important I
think it's important to speak to it so
they will quit
harassing the family over this
ancillary matter has nothing to do with
the reason why this happened to Tyree
Nichols the Scorpion unit had a pattern
and practice of doing this to black
people in Memphis that's it you don't
need to go no further than that we uh
talk about
these uh special police units or these
proactive policing
and they do this stuff and marginalized
communities of color where they on
the constitutional rights and human
rights uh black and brown citizens they
don't do that in the white communities
to White Citizens that is why Tyree
Nichols was killed because of this
excessive force policing of black
citizens thank you I live in the city of
Memphis
thank you
that was uh the lawyer for Tyree Nichols
family Ben Crump there speaking along
with Tyree Nichols mother and stepfather
reacting uh to that arraignment hearing
a little earlier in Memphis of the five
former Memphis police officers charged
with Tyree Nichols murder they entered a
plea yes guilty uh today and that is uh
that is Tony Nichols family reacting
along with the lawyer Ben Crump let's
just cross to our correspondent uh James
Matthews who's outside the courthouse
for us and was listening to that press
conference uh James uh very emotional
words there from Tyree Nichols Mother
where she said that she feels she's
living a nightmare that she's waiting
for someone to wake her up from
yeah yeah emotional indeed although I
thought she held it together uh fairly
well after a
a difficult a difficult moment being in
the same room as the individual's
accused of murdering her son glorious
was the word used by Rodney Tyree
Nichols stepfather to describe today
glorious because the criminal justice
process is kicking in they are now on a
track
at the end of which they hope to see
Justice for their son they're describing
it as a blueprint the speed with which
charges were laid against these five
individuals and you heard the thoughts
about charges possibly against a sixth
because there is a sixth officer his
name is Preston hemple and he was at the
scene
of where Tony Nichols was arrested he
was wielding the taser press it against
Tyler Nichols leg deployed that the
taser as Tyree Nichols ran away and was
held to say on his own body cam I hope
they stomp him and using profanity so
the family want to see charges brought
against him they want charges against
everybody who appeared in that very
shocking video but as they depart Shelby
courthouse today they are content as
things stand right now content that they
are seeing
a measure of justice that they want for
their departed son a difficult time
as I say in that courtroom a packed
courtroom 10 yards separated the family
with those five accused of the murder of
Tyree Nichols as their attorneys
delivered there please of not guilty
we've got a sense of how these how the
defense will play out essentially every
man for himself it appears having spoken
to a couple of attorneys and you heard
them they're talking about individual
roles on the night that indicate a
degree of Innocence on the part of
individual police officers who at this
stage they're clearly not staying
together as a unit although the
prosecution would see them very much as
having acted in concert
okay James Matthews live in Memphis for
us there thank you very much indeed for
all your coverage thank you
let's just return now to one of our
other main stories today the family of
missing mother of two Nicola bully has
told Sky News that every day is a
struggle as they wait for news Nicola's
father Ernie bully also said he hopes
the Sky News reconstruction of Nicola's
last known movements will help get some
answers it comes after the information
commissioner said he will be asking
Lancashire police to explain its
decision in why they revealed her
struggles with alcohol and the menopause
now Nicolette disappeared three weeks
ago while walking her dog in the